as everybody knows the telephone has
changed a good deal over the years but
it has also become responsible for a lot
of useful cousins whose kinship is know
was realized to name just a few there's
the teletype which speeds the written
word across the miles remote feeding of
electronic brain calculators nationwide
television transmission the remote control
of systems for industry and more familiar
the increasing use of those added telephones
which are saving so many steps today these
and a host of others made by the millions
or one of a kind are the tools of telephony
and the reason they're always at hand and ready
to serve is that some very able men and women
made them or installed them or warehouse them
near the point of use or purchased them to the
Bell System the American telephone and telegraph
company and the operating companies across the
nation this someone is the Western Electric
Company with manufacturing locations in more
than a dozen states seventeen installation areas
from coast to coast a far-flung purchasing system
and a chain of distributing houses that
covers the nation these four activities
are interdependent each must link into the
others to keep down the cost of service
nearly everything a Bell Telephone company
needs comes through orders placed on a western
electric distributing house nearby there are
over 30 of these houses and no telephone need
is more than a few hours away from these
heavy department stores of the Bell System
a thousand and more requisitions a day
come from a telephone company into a
typical distributing house nine out of
ten of them for shipment the same day
the smaller items are stored along half-mile
conveyor lines into which the
dispatcher feeds his orders
a typical house may start 10,000 different
items including 3,000 types of apparatus
and 1,800 different kinds of printed
matter although the stock turnover is
rapid on most items Western must still
keep ready to supply replacement parts
for equipment installed many years ago the
loaded hampers go to the telephone companies
loading platform for transport during the
night to telephone work centers some of
this material will be installed tomorrow
morning while it's still being billed
the trucks come back to the houses
with used equipment that has been
removed from service some of it
just needs reconditioning but
some isn't worth repair and goes
into various channels of Salvage
old cable and wire metal parts and
the like are shipped to the company
Salvage plant on Staten Island New York
where the Nassau smelting and refining
company reclaims the copper LED and other
metals this operation has been particularly
useful to the system in the recurring
periods when copper has been scarce
the distributing houses recondition all
sorts of equipment but the volume job
is on the telephone instruments themselves
which turnover faster than you might think
the disassembled instruments are classified
by the amount of work which needs to be done
and feed along the conveyor network
into the appropriate shop section
an ingenious system of pins in the travelling
boxes automatically selects the right route all
telephones get replacement parts as needed
and a thorough check out on the test panel
when nature goes on the rampage the men of the
distributing houses get on the job regardless
of hours of weather somewhere out there in
the storm other telephone men are fighting
to restore service to stricken communities
they must have tools and supplies what they
need all they need when they need them the
distributing house is ready aerial wire
drop wire pull hardware and a hundred other
necessities will be on the emergency scene
in a matter of hours to be backed up by reserve
stocks rushed from the factories it's on the way
no matter how severe the storm are
how great the damage not one man on
the reconstruction team has his work delayed
by lack of material things the Bell operating
companies need but which Western Electric
does not manufacture come from suppliers
in more than 3000 American cities and towns
the purchasing people buy them along with
all the supplies machinery and raw materials
which Western needs for its own operations
the nationwide orders add into such a volume
that these buyers can be specialists some men for
example buy nothing but wood and wood products
from plywood to poles they know as much about
their specialty as a man can know many suppliers
sell Western a big part of their output which lets
them save on sales and credit expense the Bell
company share these savings but the supplier
must make a fair profit so he'll continue to be
a healthy dependable source take these high-speed
presses for printing millions of telephone
directories often the pooling of these orders
justifies installing expensive machinery and again
Bell companies share the savings suppliers come
in all shapes and sizes some are the Giants of
American industry skilled in the manufacture of
unusual items such as these microwave antennas
and often the volume justifies keeping westerns
own inspector right in the manufacturers plant
but many of the more than 30,000 suppliers are
as small as this little enterprise which turns
out very satisfactory wooden pins for cross arms
and wherever possible purchases are made from
local merchants or dealers the billion and a
quarter dollars dispersed annually for materials
and outside services makes itself felt in many
places probably your town was one of the more
than 3,000 communities to which these checks
were mailed the purchasing people also buy the raw
materials which the company uses in its factories
copper almost a tenth of all copper consumed in
the nation steel for manufacture into thousands
of precision parts plastics for insulating wire
covering cable and making the familiar telephone
and others by the hundreds in quantities
large and small but before materials can
be processed the products they will become
must be developed and designed this is the
job of the Bell Telephone laboratories owned
jointly by Western Electric and AT&T much of
their research is fundamental investigating
the frontiers of present knowledge from one
such project came the device which will
affect our whole material way of life
the transistor new tools of telephony start in
the laboratories informally like this but they
must sometime end up like this and this is the
challenge to westerns manufacturing division
of course the factories make not only
the telephone instruments but in the
various manufacturing locations spread
over more than a dozen states they make
thousands of other tools of telephony
that most telephone users will never
see some of the plants are modest in
size some have to be very large indeed
if the production men are to hold
prices down in the face of rising
wages and material cost manufacturing
must be constantly more efficient here
is such an effort teamwork in action the
wire spring relay for switching telephone
calls and central offices came to Western from
the laboratories as an experimental model their
men worked in liaison with Western engineers
to ready the device for quantity manufacture
production would ordinarily have been set
up in standard assembly groups like this
but the stakes were high these relays
were needed by the million and westerns
development engineers said about designing
an automated machine that would perform a
whole series of complex operations in
sequence to turn out the wire spring
combs for the relay faster cheaper and
better than manual methods could ever
achieve the investment is substantial but the
economy of automated production makes it pay
the hundred and fifty thousand and more items
in these product files are of infinite variety
from huge like these reels at cable to small
coils for telephone rings wound by the million
and barista buttons for assuring quietness and
telephones to outright tiny so very tiny that
they must be processed under a microscope the
Allentown plant is in the vanguard of today's
growing trend toward miniatures Asian whereby
an entire telephone central office may someday
fit into a space no larger than the living room
it calls for precise factory techniques as in
shaping the filament for a small electron
to micro manufacturing you might call it
here a tiny grid is wound with wire the
operator can hardly see thermistor beads
act as tiny switches conducting electricity
in larger volume when hot and when cold skills
like these once rare and costly have now been
made practical for volume application wire is
always the target of nature's attacks wire in
flooded conduits wire loaded with ice why are
beaten by desert Sun and heat even unpleasant
days the relentless attack continues vulnerable
to all these hazards for example is the wire
from the pole to the subscribers house and a
new kind of wire from the Baltimore plant is
reducing this cause of service interruption
it begins with a steel core for strength a
series of plating operation coats the steel
with copper for conductivity and other
metals to resist corrosion the process
developed by westerns engineers is called
electro forming it is continuous and nearly
automatic the entire building is operated
by only six men the strong wires now coated
with copper are laid in a bed of rubber and
covered with tough neoprene to resist abrasion
a hurricane tonight would leave
this floor nearly bare tomorrow
another new type of telephone wire coated
with colored plastic at 2,000 feet per minute
will provide the long years of trouble-free
service the telephone system has to demand
reducing red-hot billets of copper to wire
brings out some unusual teamwork
between the men and their machines
each time the hot copper passes between
rollers it becomes thinner when down to
a quarter-inch it is ready to
be cleaned and drawn into wire
here are the wires enter a huge machine
which insulates them with a coat of paper
the insulated wires then come together in a bundle
these cable units are combined on a custom basis
more or fewer of them according to the needs of
the telephone company the whole cable may contain
over 4,000 individual wires enclosed in one sheath
today protective plastic replaces
the traditional lead sheath on many
cables in the future the sheath may be
of aluminum formed directly on the cable
to the manufacturing engineer no process is
ever final intricate wiring for telephone
switching equipment slow to make by
hand now flows from a machine which
starts with wire on spools a small network a
complicated assembly of miniature components
needed in every telephone now it gets its
program of tests on an automatic machine
this little glass-enclosed switch compact and
positive when made by hand costs too much for
widespread use so the engineers developed a
machine which is a miniature factory in itself
starting with metal parts and glass tubing
going through a self-controlled sequence
of operations checking itself for quality and
delivering the switches in great quantity at a
fraction of their old price the little signal
lamps which flash on telephone switchboards
right up the sometimes overlooked fact that
automation must be applied with common sense
despite the huge volume of these
tiny labs 10 million of them are
made each year the clever machines
still need the supervision of human
hands deft hands controlled by
human intelligence and judgment
a gleaming crystal of germanium spins up from
a batch of molten metal ready to be sliced
into the tiny wafer which is the heart of the
transistor the growing family of transistors is
dropping in cost as mass production engineering
continues compact and cool transistors use so
little current the today's familiar telephone
bell which rings on eighty five volts may
someday be replaced by a transistorized
musical tone which needs only one vote
the Indianapolis plant is a good example of
modern volume manufacture here are made the
telephone instruments themselves seven
million of them in a single year a few
ounces of plastic become a handset housing in
seconds by the use of a polished steel die that
took six months to make and cost fifty five
thousand dollars a set again expensive tools
that cut production costs are made feasible by
pooling the orders of all the Bell companies
color rides the conveyor lives today colors to
go with any decor and convenience to match the
color wall telephones bedroom telephones speaker
phones volume control phones illuminated dials
and answering sets and each must be engineered
both for convenience and use and for production
at a feasible price an ideal fusion of machines
and people and despite the machines still a lot
of people in a typical year Western pays nearly
three quarters of a billion dollars to its many
thousands of men and women a third of whom
have been with the company for 10 years or
more from the vast Kearney plant and from the
even bigger Hawthorne works comes the equipment
for automatically switching telephone calls
in central offices engineers custom design
each addition or expansion from files which
detail every central office in the bell system
since no two towns are alike every central office
must be different so the combination of frames
amplifiers and so on is tailored to the particular
community requirement but this custom combination
is then built out of standard volume produced
units which differ in number rather than design
the wire wrapping gun which makes connections
without solder is saving time as well as solder
on assemblies like this these huge frames
for a new central office are just one part
of the world's biggest electronic brain
the bail system plant where a person can
put a problem into the computer in Seattle
and seconds later get his answer from Miami
a typical operating company order for
central office equipment calls on Western
to engineer furnish and install from factory
merchandise docks the equipment goes out to
westerns installers installers working out
of headquarters in 16 far-flung cities are
the Marines of the system the mobile force
the proles into a town moves into an empty
space in the telephone building and proceeds
to fill it with pulsing clicking equipment
this job has been in active preparation for
many months and the supervisors have enough
blueprints and specifications to paper the walls
of their big room 10 times over the job begins
new men learned from the old hands
mastering one skill and moving
on to a more difficult one until
they become old hands themselves
the hundreds of wires in each of these cables
are to the layman as alike as blades of grass
but each one of the thousands of strands has
its own origin and seeks its own destination
in a single year westerns installers
may connect two million dial lines
the custom-made apparatus flows from the
factories to the job each frame and panel
skidded to its predetermined place on a schedule
set up before most of it was manufactured
quite a crew these installers scattered in small
groups from coast to coast but effectively is
close together as though all of them are in the
same room working with the same tools on units
manufactured to the same specifications making
connections to tie in with other circuits being
connected at the same moment by distant men
whom they may never meet so that a call placed
at any one of the millions of telephones in
the system can get an answer from any other
telephone and to do it so dependably that the
caller will keep right on taking his tools of
telephony for granted now the job is nearing
completion and the Western supervisor and the
telephone company wire chief bring their people
together into the team that will test and check
and observe until this infinitely complex
web of circuits is proven ready for service
every connection every switch every
relay in the thousands of circuits
will either check out okay or drop a card
automatically punched to spot what is wrong
okay and the time grows shorter coordinating
committees from Western and the telephone
company matched their schedules and point for
the big date the hour of the cut over and now
the new office meets its major challenge the
load test which dumps a flood of simulated
calls in much greater volume than should ever
come through the cables if it passes this
it passes finished like 99% of the projects
on the scheduled date and the force now ready
to move on says goodbye to its local friends the
supervisor stuffs the last of his papers into his
familiar brown briefcase and moves on to the next
job today a substantial part of westerns manpower
and machines is devoted to the national defense
from one plant comes the fantastically complicated
Nike guided missile system which will locate a sky
borne invader track him and guide the warhead to
the killed two trained men of the Navy Army and
Air Force in using the new electronic weapons
which Western produces members of the field
engineering force follow the flag wherever it goes
and it goes to some fireplaces to span the Arctic
wastes with the 3,000 mile line of radar stations
known as the dew line the government called on
the company's unique experience in organizing
new and complicated undertakings 200 thousand
tons of equipment and supplies had to be moved
into a forbidding region and then installed here
where once the man considered himself lucky just
to stay alive he dropped huge bulldozers from
the skies as a matter of below-zero routine to
complete this new frontier of defense unscheduled
in just 32 months at home the facilities of the
company expand with the needs of the nation new
factories new distributing houses more employees
but the Spirit is still Western Electric
a nationwide structure built on more than
three-quarters of a century of service to the
Bell companies and a telephone users service
in purchasing the most suitable materials at the
fairest price distributing the materials to the
right place at the right time manufacturing
tools of telephony to serve dependably for
decades and service in installing the tools to
meet the ever-increasing needs of a whole nation
of customers service in the final analysis by
people thousands of loyal and industrious men
and women without whom even the finest plant
would be only brick concrete and dead metal
over the years of miracle has come to pass
until today any person can talk directly
voiced to ear with any other person in our
whole country and in much of the world abroad
clearly quickly and it's low cost so the most
active period of America's growth it has been
the privilege of the Western Electric Company
to engineer furnish and install the tools of
telephony to the end that the progress of the
past may serve as the promise of the future
you